Черговий виток
газової війни з Росією
2018 року
знову поновив дискусії
про відмову від імпортного газу
за рахунок власного виробництва.
Та скільки газу насправді
може видобувати Україна?
Україна може пишатися одними з найбільших
покладів газу в Європі. Вона -
в топ-четвірці Європи за газовими
покладами: разом з Росією,
Норвегією та Нідерландами.
В підземних надрах України -
від шестисот мільярдів до понад трильйона
кубометрів доведених
покладів газу.
І щонайменше уп’ятеро більше, згідно
з непідтвердженими розрахунками.
Усі ці природні
багатства зосереджені в трьох головних
нафтогазоносних районах.
Найбільше видобутку в Східному,
або Дніпровсько-Донецькому басейні,
з якого викачано тільки трохи
більше половини -
58% підтверджених покладів.
Із Західного,
або Карпатського басейну підняли
усього 45% газу.
Найменш розроблений Південий,
або Причорноморсько-Кримський басейн –
на 8%.
Після анексії Криму Росія
захопила українські шельфові родовища,
і видобуток там тимчасово
неможливий.
Перш за все – за допомогою реформи
усієї галузі. Уряд схвалив
її два роки тому
в рамках "Стратегії сталого розвитку - 2020".
Якщо виконати все заплановане,
видобуток зросте до 30 мільярдів кубометрів
й купувати газ
не доведеться. Проте Україна
вже не встигає за графіком.
Найбільші проблеми: засилля
бюрократичного регулювання,
вплив олігархів та корупція.
Так, у 2017-му
не провели жодного аукціону
з надання нових дозволів
на розробку родовищ.
Водночас минулого року
обласні ради відмовились погодити
майже 80 раніше наданих
дозволів, бо мають таке право
згідно з законодавством.
Все це гальмує розвиток
галузі та сповільнює
нарощення видобутку.
Тож наразі -  із 32 мільярдів кубометрів газу,
які Україна спожила
минулого року,
лише 20 мільярдів кубів
були власними.